um
the star of the show is Call of Duty
right the reach Call of Duty even kind
of more than mobile games in this way
has shown that it has this ability to
thrive year in and year out with a new
product even when products are kind of
mid right and not up to the level of
what people expect from Call of Duty
every single year uh I kind of don't
understand it but I see it and I can't
deny that it exists so this is the star
of this show regardless of all the
underlying things that make it make it
viable and make it worthy of doing um
that are just smaller in scale nah you
can't do it without Cod I'd walk away
without Cod yeah pay that three billion
hey it's not gonna work I'm sorry but
I'm not doing it without Devil's
Advocate real quick interrupt what about
prior statements that right the deal was
solely about mobile we can't exist
without the mobile market in our foot so
that's the real thing I think what we've
all